there's no shortage of scandals in
esports from match fixing to cheating it
can get pretty dark but today we wanted
to talk about a different kind of
scandal the kind of scandal that leaves
you scratching your head and thinking
what the [ __ ] is happening but before we
get into it i have to remind you as
always hit the like button the subscribe
button and to ring the notification bell
and when you're done buckle up kiddo
because today we're counting down the
top 10 most ridiculous scandals in
esports
starting this list off is the time zombs
decide to go and piss off an entire
region for no apparent reason
not just for me but because there are
some people there who are being [ __ ]
talking our region and our nation and
saying things the bad things about our
day-to-day life and our daily
difficulties it would be great to be
able to face them for myself for
personal reasons and to shut them up a
little everyone knows latin american
esports has one of the most passionate
fan bases in the world thanks in part to
their success across so many games
including valerian not even able to get
to half the show stopper online to buy
some space devices
able to get two but this one mystic
snatch it back crew down to two
oh my gosh it's all down to dome of the
1v1 he's got the alt
unfortunately for sentinel zombs he
didn't realize that he should probably
watch his tone when [ __ ] talking a
combined population of over 600 million
people we are actually gonna come back
to this bit of drama later in the list
but essentially shazam made a joke at
the expense of brazilian teams furya and
team vikings fans on twitter did not
take it very well then zombs decided to
make it 10 times worse flexing your
watches and tweeting stuff like can't
wait to beat your [ __ ] region might not
be the smartest move but you know what
they say revenge is a dish best served
on lan
klaus ready and holding though dapper
it's your time to shine right about now
it's all on you buddy surrounded all
fronts it's over it's done with crew
against all
of our expectations against all odds
send sentinels
next up at number nine is ice poseidon
and his alleged crypto scam yeah i could
give the money back it is within my
power um
but i'm gonna look out for myself and
not do that i i you know i don't like
know what else to say that's just the
most honest answer ice poseidon is no
stranger to controversy so it's no
surprise that he somehow got himself
involved in a crypto rug pull ice
started a crypto coin called cx coin and
things were going mostly okay until
youtuber coffeezilla called him out
according to coffeezilla ice was
allegedly doing a classic pump and dump
scam ice poseidon's scheme apparently
took him only two weeks of work to set
up before he apparently got bored with
the project and decided to stop working
on it and just took the money the worst
part is that ice beside him was already
salivating over the idea of doing a rug
pull you're telling me i could create
a cx coin and then people could buy it
because i could say that the community
is super strong and then i could sell it
in 10 seconds and make 10 million
dollars what the [ __ ] i'm doing i'm
sitting here taking donations instead
what the [ __ ] am i doing it just comes
down to the trust because you know i
don't you i mean if i was you i run off
with the bag
tell me when it's pumped and then i'm
out and then i'll see you later
coffeezilla alleges that ice made it off
with over three hundred thousand dollars
of investors money meanwhile isiden
claims that he removed three hundred
thousand from the liquidity pool due to
an impending market crash but
coffeezilla and scorned investors didn't
believe that for a second it doesn't
seem like a joke anymore it seems like
you scammed your fans uh no not a not a
scam um you don't think we're drawing
300k is is a scam
our eighth spot goes to riot's bizarre
ruling over a furious exploit used at
ballarant champions lining up at the
back wall all the sentinels players
firing off together in cosmic very
important flank through there's the hole
too there's a stick can he find it got
it
he can still fury are alive the rebel
clutched their forensic er valerian's
first major ended up being more of a
[ __ ] show than most expected and a lot
of the drama had to do with some of
wright's weird rulings on exploits of
course there was the illegal cipher cam
that vivoki's stars used which led them
having to replay their match but there
was a far crazier situation that same
tournament what they're doing is they're
dwindling the rounds where they can
actually try real strats and
they're becoming more and more readable
on those rounds sentinels only needed
one round to close it out but furious
was mounting what could have been an
insane comeback however a tech pause was
called by one of the refs to discuss the
legality of a jump boost done by furya
the pause ended up lasting almost 20
minutes freya lost all their momentum
and immediately lost the next round
backside spike down they know where he
is they know where that drone came from
he's going to have to make this oh my
god ted's going up with the updraft and
comes down and slams into ncr with the
daggers and carries sentinels across the
finish line
our seventh absurd scandal is the time
hungrybox got a little crabby the crap
oh he's saying someone threw that at him
just because hungrybox won oh that
person is okay
hungrybox is one of the greatest melee
players of all time his accomplishments
are legendary
[Applause]
unfortunately when you're as good as
hbox is you end up with some haters
haters who will apparently throw crabs
at you that's right at pound 2019 just
after hbox won the entire tournament
someone threw a crab at him
[Applause]
[Music]
who threw this at me
oh dude
why would you throw something
right in my face
you know
hbox was of course reasonably upset but
now that we're a few years out we can
all admit that this was kind of
hilarious plus hbox even got revenge on
the crab
in the sixth position is the scandal
that can be summarized by two words help
sewer
helping i need to help sewers guys
thrifty
at the 2022 vct open qualifier tsm were
facing off against t1 when all of a
sudden there was a long tech pause that
ended with t1 forfeiting the match
spectators had no idea what was going on
tsm was [ __ ] posting and subrosa was
accusing t1 of cheating eventually ryan
confirmed that t1's coach was illegally
communicating with the team via all chat
are you allowed to say what the coach
typed he said rosa
and i was like yo what the [ __ ]
the coach was suspended and his cry to
help sewers was memed into oblivion they
were using vpn to like
make their ping higher and [ __ ]
disgusting
all right
like whatever bro
breaking us into the top five is the
jumping bug controversy from the 2017
pgl major if they don't win this they
don't come back go down onward one big
still have a large job ahead of them
let's be honest if they're gonna make a
play off
but it's not from the realm of
possibility that we get two or three
challenging teams in especially with g2
as a challenging team cloud nine now
they played in cologne tabs in how he's
playing right now for big as he goes
aggressive nico and allu stand no chance
players figured out that in certain
areas of maps like inferno's banana
players could see over obstacles without
being noticed if they crouched at the
right moment now this bug was in the
game for a while before the 2017 major
and certainly several players and teams
used it but all the heat went to big who
abused the [ __ ] out of the exploit while
facing faze wants to keep getting in
their grills and shutting them down
bathed in by lakia which is jumping up
with the flashbang as well once a spot
one player flash down and allow tabs in
to potentially get two or three kills in
that spot
a nice little setup
ski player we'll see if it works out for
them there's a flash tabs and faces
doesn't get anything for it just yet but
niko seems to think something's going on
there it was so bad that all 16 teams
got together and made a collective
gentleman's agreement to abstain from
doing it
taking the fourth spot on our list is
the fgc's insane tom brady incident now
before you get confused we are not
talking about the football guy this tom
brady is a mortal combat player who used
to stream regularly on twitch
essentially this tom brady was raising
money through twitch donations to go to
nec 2019 and pennsylvania he raised 600
but then no showed and got disqualified
it seemed like a regular old scam but
things got weird when tom tried to
defend himself tom claimed he flew to
philadelphia where the event was taking
place but the uber to the event itself
was too expensive
just show me the receipt and then i'll
be like all right you're right i was
wrong but until you show me november
30th on a thursday that you will receive
you're full of [ __ ] to prove he actually
went to philly he showed the uber
receipts from his time there except
those receipts were clearly photoshopped
and the dates weren't just wrong they
didn't exist he also said he had spent
all of the money to buy a new ps4
because the airlines somehow lost his
you want me to return the ps4 pig
is that going to make you feel better
eventually evo champion sonic fox showed
up to own tom so hard he basically
vanished from the fgc when you said on
november 30th
thursday that you are in new jersey do
you are you seeing the issue here okay
so what you're saying is
you want to know
thursday you want to know where i was
the issue here during this time period
here no i want to know where you were on
november 30th thursday
coming in third place is csgo's most
notorious land gaming paradise
close your eyes and imagine a beautiful
tropical island with gourmet food 5 star
service and tier 1 cs go you might be
thinking that sounds like fire fest for
sweaty nerds and you would be 100
correct gaming paradise was a cs go
event that promised teams a festival of
music drinks and gaming what they got
was something very different
[Applause]
to no surprise the event was a disaster
the internet was dog [ __ ] the weather
was uncooperative and the organizers
could even get pcs to run the tournament
on on top of all of that some staff and
players even got their passports
confiscated by police all in all not one
of csgo's brightest moments bad thing
that happened today uh one of our staff
members from gaming rs approached me and
told me that he can't get his passport
our second spot on the list goes to the
sketchy as hell save the kids crypto
scam
my name's frasier my name is jarvis i'm
tyco i'm ricegum i'm nikon and i support
save the kids token save the kids token
save the kids token save the kids token
save the kids token
yes we are back at it again with another
crypto pump and dump scandal but this
time fez clan's very own kay and jarvis
got involved save the kids was supposed
to be a charitable crypto coin that had
a percentage of its worth going to help
children in need i have spent like 30
minutes just vetting this myself and
have come to the conclusion that this is
something that is wholly unreliable it
is using save the kids in order to
create this weird token that is so
obviously pump and dump that anybody
alright even with the worst eyesight
could have seen this coming so how is it
that these influencers with actual
marketing teams actual teams themselves
didn't come to this conclusion and it
seems like to an extent some of them did
shockingly as soon as the coin went live
the price plummeted significantly and
investors immediately started accusing
the influencers of participating in a
pump and dump the phase members involved
were quickly fired or suspended and faze
clan distanced themselves from what is a
highly illegal activity um all of faze
knew about this the entire time uh you
don't like it sue me i know for a fact
every motherf in this team knows exactly
what's happening so it's funny for them
to kick people out and be like oh we had
no idea [ __ ] i guarantee you that
they're selling these uh they're selling
these deals to their teams or whatever
and they'll be like oh listen man it's
cool all you do is you buy it and then
you sell immediately after it's all good
dude you'll make a ton of money
guarantee there's no way that like
they're just passing these deals on like
oh well i don't know man good luck
figure out how to do it
coming in first place is the controversy
that shook the world of counter-strike
the coaching bug look at this
spectate bug from the coach like
how is this even possible cisgo you need
to fix this there's been like tons of
official games back in 2020 and 2021
freelance cs go referee miho slowinski
uncovered a huge scandal he discovered
that coaches were using an exploit at
the highest level of cs go competition
it's heroic versus astralis it's the
match where hunden for the first 10
rounds had a coach camera or had a
camera and free cam on banana the bug he
found allowed coaches to potentially
watch rounds play out from anywhere on
the map coaches could then use the stuck
camera position to get information on
the other team mid-round the esports
integrity commission launched an
investigation and three coaches
including heroic's hundin or banned
we're as close to a sport as you can
possibly get in terms of esports
competitive integrity integrity is the
most important thing that we have at
this point once people don't trust what
they're watching
everything else is out the window and so
that must be protected at all costs
since then more than 37 coaches have
been banned for using what is now
referred to as hundencam
all right folks that's it those are the
top 10 most ridiculous esports scandals
that we could find if you think we
missed one let us know down in the
comment section below take care of
yourselves and others and i'll see you
in the next one
you guys want to hear the most
ridiculous thing what the admin said
okay the admin said
you can do the sea jump but you're not
allowed to do it with jet's passive
ability so if you're jet and you want to
do this jump you have to do it the way
like without the passive and then it's
allowed but if you use jet's passive in
any shape and form then it's illegal i
don't know how that makes any sense at
all